do your best impression of Keira
Knightley as the sugarplum fairy
walkabout sky with me joshing haste and
today we're joined by the new
nut-cracking crackit astok star
Mackenzie for now what I loved about
this is this like a nice collection of
badass girls in there
there's Kyra there's you there's Helen
Mirren what was that kind of like female
call Marjorie like on set it was really
fun I mean Kyra and Miss Helen there of
course as a lot of people know these
incredible very empowering very strong
women and then seeing them on set and
our in our amazing costumes and we're
just like I hope they had like that
little thing with the wrap and the
vegetables yeah it was really fun
there's just such incredible women and
they're truly truly kind and wonderful
people you know in regular life what do
you think you learned about empowerment
from them would you say they're just
naturally strong and confident and they
really embrace that so I would say
embracing that confidence of knowing who
you are which is a good message for the
film because it's about self-discovery
it is about self-discovery and that is
what you really what Clara learns in the
film to believe in that strength inside
of yourself yeah well babe we are gonna
put you to the test now with your Disney
knowledge didn't intend okay to see if
you're the ultimate Disney star okay I'm
a huge Disney fan so if I failed this
I'll be very disappointed to myself well
get your game face on babe and we're
ready to go okay
complete the lyric a whole new world a
new Fantastic point of view babe yes
which character in The Little Mermaid
sings under the sea yes babe you're
killing this already which fictional
Kingdom does Elsa come from in frozen oh
yes
in ladyandtramp what did the pair of
lovers famously share yes you were good
who plays ball in the live-action remake
of beating the beasts Don which
musicians sang with the circle of life
in Lion King
no musician yeah I'll give you clue fee
famous in the cartoon I don't know it's
out and John ah behaves you are the
ultimate Disney star you can slip into
any character you slate that quiz Bay
okay except for the Lion King part
yeah but I'm ending John how could ya I
mean if you watch this out and I'm sorry
awkward or Keys babe